what is up welcome to another episode of
get close i'm your co-host gio and i'm
bart and today we have a very special
guest one of my favorite this this homie
in the room right now has been a
ride-or-die
um for at least
six or seven years we've had this person
um if you if if you identify as a person
i'm sorry i don't think so
um but you were here before tycho was
ever here and mr bear i'm so happy to
have you here um he's a little sick so
he's not gonna be talking much but
honestly we've had this [ __ ] bear
sitting in a chair if you're listening
there's no guest we have a bear like
those big ass giant costco bears today
and um the minute i laid my eyes on this
guy i wanted him i'm like i love him and
we ended up buying these bears for our
parents yes yeah we got three of them
one for my two of them one for each dad
no three one for taika
one for yourself
oh really yep oh just two of them so
yeah number three one for us oh right
one right here and then we and the one
for my dad yeah and then we ended up
getting them all back yeah anyway so i
know i know the title i get it stop
stalling let's just jump into it yes
we are planning on having another baby
start over why you didn't address uh
that we're happy to be able to do the
two it's just to you and me
oh i just felt i stalled so much with
this then we'll ignore this one line and
then we'll hit it with the uh
yeah you want to reset it no we'll just
roll okay okay so that was just a
practice and uh this is the real one
three
two one hey what's up welcome to another
episode of get close i'm your co-host
gio and i'm bart and today we have a
very special guest this big ass bear
sitting in our chair that we've had
longer than we've had taika and um today
we just wanted a vibe we just wanted a
mama bear papa bear conversation i'm
looking at your crotch and you have a
big [ __ ] and it's very distracting i
did that on purpose thank you you know
what i'm saying and that's why i'm kind
of happy you don't have a guest today
yeah cause uh me and geo get to get a
little bit personal like we used to that
i miss a lot i do too and then
afterwards you know get a little
personal and personal
i've got [ __ ] up because tucker does a
lot of beatboxing now that's true um but
no i like this i feel like we've been so
slammed and we've been so busy that we
just don't really get to connect yeah
and slammed in terms of like business
slammed in terms of parenting slammed in
terms of just schedule um and we've had
so many dope ass friends that we've been
wanting to put on and also share their
story yeah that we jam-packed it and
then we're like oh you know what we miss
just when we used to just talk about our
lives you know get more in depth in
detail because when we have these talks
it's very intentional yeah it's you and
me
zoned in we're not worrying about who's
gonna cook dinner washing dishes tiger
running around or anything like that you
know it's just
you and me and it's really intimate and
it reminds me of our old ones we had the
super ghetto set up but at least now i
get to look at you straight on oh yeah
like this weird that was kind of weird
i just i was like sitting here watching
uh like watching you speak and i was
like why does this feel weird and it's
because yeah we just never really looked
at each other yeah we're making intense
eye contact and i love it i really love
it i love talking to you [ __ ] i wish i
would have put in my contacts you're
kind of a little bit blurry are you
serious yeah so you tell me i got all
dolled up just so you can't look at me
no you look great i just it's just a
little fuzzy that's what i [ __ ]
thought it's just a little fuzzy okay so
are we gonna talk about
what we're gonna talk about oh
yeah
right so as the title
already tells you
um oh one other thing i want to add the
reason why i really like these talks was
just you and me
and um
it's you know with our vlogs and stuff
we
just try to capture all the coolest
memories of our life
right like things that we think are cool
moments when friends visit big
milestones and taika's life and our life
and stuff but
those are all just like coverage pieces
you know like we document it
but in these one-on-one podcasts we
actually dive deep into some of those
milestones yeah which i think is so cool
you know like recently we had joe come
over and he was hanging out and we went
hiking and all that but to be able to
dive deep into why
he went on all these travels in the last
like year or two did you know all that
stuff that we talked about did you know
that that's where his heart and his head
was um a little bit you know cause like
when you don't have an intentional
conversation sometimes podcast
conversations are even better than real
conversations because we might be
chilling at a vietnamese restaurant
right we're ordering and then it is
talking about oh man you got that sick
tacoma have you gone off-roading yet
yeah man so i plan on going to utah and
like okay well you want to order man you
want this you want that did you and then
you're just like whoa whoa and then by
the time they they leave and then
another guest joins us oh man i've seen
you guys a long time oh what's up
anthony how you been how's ken just and
then it's already like the two or three
sentences we got in the travel mode or
you're not crying at a restaurant you're
not trying to yeah it goes
pow and so with the intentional one it's
like yo man
i've been seeing this or this happen
tell me all about it and it's so cool
like this topic right the topic that we
have yet to talk about yeah we really
didn't talk about it i think it was one
of those where
um
taika came into the picture so even
before taika we always said or i always
said that i wanted um multiple kids
and then what was your number remember
before we got married yeah it was four
and i was like oh that's good because i
want five
yeah it was four
and then i also said in the beginning of
our relationship that i as soon as kids
are entering the picture i didn't want
to work anymore yeah um because i grew
up with
parents that were
always gone
not as much as yours yeah um i was
definitely not a latchkey kid by any
means but
i remember a phase in my life when i was
in high school i believe that my mom um
she had surgery
um and she needed to be home from work
my mom's the type of person that does
not miss work like she's punctual
she's very dependable
um she never gets sick and if she does
get sick she just doesn't know how to
like
chill i know i remember we went to go
watch the
paw patrol concert in vegas yeah and
your mom had like food poisoning oh
right and even then she still kept
herself i can't even tell it was normal
business as usual yeah i think like we
were um all getting ready to leave to go
to the concert and your mom got ready
first of course because we got to get
tyke already right so we're getting him
ready and your mom is already outside of
the hotel room and you know like hotel
room doors when they lock they lock on
or when they close they lock by
themselves it closes then i hear like
not even like
dude
i'm like uh yes maj goes um i need to
use
the bathroom oh yeah sure come on and
then open and then she kind of like
tiptoes in and she goes
you saw that yeah she was just like and
then you see like like the pouring sweat
on her forehead and she looks pale and
i'm like ma just go i could tell she's
about to yak or [ __ ] or pants or [ __ ]
whatever and then she's like it's not
gonna be it's not gonna be nice i'm like
don't worry we're gonna leave this room
you have all the privacy let it all out
yeah you know and then what's her
biggest fear too yeah we go in the
hallway and we're just waiting
and she comes out she goes
i don't think i'm gonna make it guys
i'm like just take a nap you don't need
to no i think she hold it all the way
she made it but she was just like i
think i needed to lay down for a little
bit maybe yeah maybe it was for the it
was like so small yeah maybe it was a
dinner after or something but there was
one thing we all went to go do it like
she did the main concert but whatever we
went to go do after whatever she's like
i ain't doing that she's like i'm just
gonna stay and i'm like do whatever you
gotta do yeah so having that person
which is dope as a parent and then
uh not really knowing what i was missing
until she had surgery and she was
uh bedridden for i think like maybe even
a week
coming home and then having her be super
involved in my life was like
it just it just took me
i don't know it just took me to a
different place in in like my heart that
i'm like holy [ __ ] i love this this was
so cool i never like my mom was really
involved like my mom knew all my friends
all my friends parents she knew where i
was at every minute of the day
um so she's super involved but never
like on a personal level you know and as
a teenager too like you're [ __ ] at
least i was a piece of [ __ ]
so i can see how i was super withdrawn
and i was probably super annoying but
having her be there and be soft and like
not feel stressed from work or whatever
and and having her ask questions like
how was your day
i was like oh [ __ ] but did you see like
a night of night and day difference with
your mom from
working and then from not having no work
and being a absolute house mom yeah
absolutely because um again she didn't
have these stressors you know like there
was an excuse for her to be
in bed and for to be home and to be
sitting down because my mom calls
herself a little spider like she's not
she doesn't know how not to do stuff
yeah she's like being idle she does she
hates it
so um getting a taste of that i told
myself that
i would do everything in my power to
provide that for my future kids because
you felt what it feels like to have
the mom at home and the warmth that it
provided yeah
so then tyga comes into the picture i
also do
before you say that i also want to
apologize
that i don't think i ever took
what you said seriously yeah no you
didn't
no i know because when you said that you
wanted to be a um a stay-at-home mom
i think i have i think this is both a
as someone i know loves to say this a
gift and a curse
and it's a gift
because i i'm good at zooming out
and i can see things for what they are
and not bad or
good or right or wrong but more for
what what is the statistics or
probability of something being
reality but at
that's the gift part the curse part
is um
i think sometimes i neglect other
people's feelings
sometimes
sometimes
and
so for example a lot of the time i know
i know so for example you're better now
for sure so for when you said that right
yeah i zoomed out
and i go okay cool two 23 year olds
um
how many people say that what's the
chances of that happening in the modern
age
not very much
she's knee-deep in creatives
i'm knee-deep in creatives
are we going to be able to have that so
i was just looking at career trajectory
the how much you can take uh
uh take someone at that age what they
say seriously right like for example
taika says he wants to be a chef he's
four years old
97 percent chance probably he's not
gonna be a chef
you know so like i take all yeah but you
and i were pretty extreme people when we
say we're gonna do some [ __ ] it's
it's pretty much we're gonna do some
[ __ ] you know like
um i think
both you and i have shown each other
that once we commit to an idea yeah it's
hard for us to stray from that idea so
the minute that you incepted that idea
yeah i go cool 99 chance it's probably
gonna happen right yeah but each day
that goes on where we don't plan for it
then it kind of loses a percent
that's how i work right someone that
goes oh man i'm gonna go on this like
this uh weight loss journey i'm oh hell
yeah dude i got your back come to
barbell you're the homie you come train
for free for 30 days you know yeah they
skipped the first week in my mind i'm
like okay 70 percent chance probably not
happening yeah yeah two weeks later yo
man what's that carl's jr all about oh
it's not happening at all and then so i
think for us everything that we did we
had a plan you know we wanted to build
barbell we wanted to do jk we structured
our day okay we're gonna we're gonna
write from 11 to whatever
but with our family theme we never hit
milestones like okay this is the
available time we're going to need in
the date to have kids this is what we
think will make us financially stable
like the very big key things to living
that stay at home lifestyle that we want
um
we never really planned for it
well we didn't need to because i mean
financially we're really [ __ ] good
you know what i mean
and we are our own bosses yes and no
because financially we're good with
double income
right so even with solo income it's
really [ __ ] good yeah but the pen the
demand but we're still in la
you know so it's like la it's like
you buy a million dollar home and it
still needs repairs right like if you
want to be inside inside l.a so it's
just
from and that's what i'm saying that's
the curse part of me
where i looked at things so numerically
and logistically that when things
started playing out i'm like oh okay
i guess that's not happening and so
that's what i'm apologizing now based
off of the logic that i had i never
one i think i never um
it never felt like it was going to go
through and two
i didn't respect the emotional part
enough to where i go you know what this
means a lot for mar bear
and if she's not gonna start the
planning maybe i should
yeah i mean we've had this conversation
already too so like um a lot of these
things are hashed out so excuse me if
i'm not like
um
emotionally like
if i seem emotionally withdrawn like
we've had this conversation you've
apologized uh one of the reasons he also
said to in the past was that you just
you just didn't see me as someone that
would want that like you assumed that
being a stay-at-home mom was something
that was beneath my skill set um
not beneath your skill set yeah
but outside of the personality you have
expressed in the last three years
in these last three years in the last
three years since you've spoken
what the [ __ ] does that mean
so at the time
at the time of when those words exited
your oral cavity like when we were
dating yes uh-huh before jk before any
of that uh when the jk starts two
because i wasn't in jk yet when we had
this conversation yeah yeah two even
like two three years into jk yeah just
that whole period
i'm like oh okay it doesn't seem like of
course at that point i hated your guts
and you hated my guts not three years
into jk all right i was like five years
into jquery okay fine yeah so like i
just because you have such clear-cut
numbers i'm like is that really the time
it is it very is
shut up that's i mean
and that's what i'm saying it's a gift
and a curse yeah where like i see things
and i'm like oh okay cool this was
driving around with the spare tire on
his car i don't think he really cares
about his car he would have got to swap
out yeah i guess i i do take your
apology but you were absolutely off
right like your your mental math is cool
when it comes to um
like uh
inanimate objects i guess
um because when it came to the people
part of things yeah you just kind of
took it however you wanted to take it
without having a conversation with me
yeah and we had like just the shittiest
time together you know yeah um
so of course i didn't i didn't want to
have kids like i just didn't want
anything anymore i didn't even know what
i wanted i was just like i'm just gonna
put my head down and
and and just work and then it wasn't
until you and i started fixing
everything that i was like oh [ __ ] this
seems like it's a healthy
uh relationship now where we can
introduce the conversation of having
another kid and i think when you said
first kid having a yeah the first kid
sorry um and then when things were
healthy between us then that's when the
actual planning happened and then that's
when
um
we got pregnant
um or i got pregnant and no we got
pregnant all right
it's 20 22. we got to say the right word
right okay fine we both shared [ __ ]
the same
first trimester [ __ ] woes
and um
and uh and at that point the me staying
back and being a full-time mom was
actually a real thing
and i did it i did it for like a good
two years i believe
but i didn't get to do it in a way where
not fully i think they're still like
half in half out there's still work
stresses kind of not really though like
yeah i was i was out i was out and but
you were still waking up at 4am doing
like barbell brigade stuff
um not really no
i was doing more jk stuff like barbecue
they're in like pandemic stuff we're
still like waking up at 4 00 a.m
no
okay so that's like year three yeah
you're talking about year one year two
yeah i see yeah okay
your phone went off uh i apologize
that's it it's okay
there's gonna be a lot of apologizing in
this [ __ ] video
um
yeah so for at least the first year
solid
um a first year and a half maybe i was
still doing jk
uh i wasn't doing so much barbell like
you had taken a lot of that off yeah and
jk i didn't really see as work because
at that point i had already diminished
so much of my
like day-to-day duties i think at that
point i was probably just cast
and just being cast is a [ __ ] right you
get a call sheet which means which means
uh this is where you're gonna show up
this is how much time we're gonna film
this is how you need a dress this is
what we're filming
i get this call she i just show up and i
just shoot the [ __ ] as geo myself and it
was fun as [ __ ] yeah
um
yeah so then um i get a taste of that
but i feel guilty the entire time
because i'm just like i just left my
whole team behind i left you behind i
just couldn't contribute and it just
didn't feel right it didn't feel i
didn't feel comfortable i didn't have
the full-time mom experience that i
wanted how come it didn't feel right if
you wanted to be a mom the whole time
and you finally got it
why doesn't it feel right to go like hey
see you later team this is what i've
been wanting i just felt it was [ __ ]
up i just felt it was too abrupt
um i just felt yeah i just felt it was
just really mean i just didn't think i
i don't know maybe um at that point i
just wasn't mentally where i am now
maybe you have more of a heart than you
put on
hey i've changed a lot a lot of that
public perception i have a lot of heart
because that's like i'm doing a lot of q
a with like um with my community on
instagram and stuff and like i show
nothing but heart all the goddamn time
i'm all heart because that's me like
saying like hey man i just want to be
like an action hero right ever since day
one like when i'm five but i didn't see
that play and then and then i finally
like
get it like marvel's like no no marv
marvel guy already got their asian dc's
like yo there could be a ton of asians
dude yeah maybe the first asian
wolverine there's a multiverse so maybe
on the first asian wolverine and they're
like yo
we need you and then i'm like
you know what
but the jk family
i think i'll bounce
i'm like what yeah what this is what
i've been wanting to do it's different
it's different because um i had changed
so much
i had changed so much i thought i was
one way and then i wasn't
um and i mean it's i think it's okay for
people to to change right i think it's
not you're not allowed to change on the
internet yeah that's true on the
internet whatever you say in 2017 it is
you better be you have to die by it in
2030. yeah it's so interesting how
people view
people online as like not human yeah
it's so interesting to me
um
so yeah the entire time that i'm away
from barbell
i feel shitty
so then i think around year three the
hike is year three then i'm like okay
i'll come back um and just being
pregnant too i just didn't i've said
this so many times on so many different
platforms but i just didn't like it i
just felt
super incapable i just didn't like the
feeling of it like i like obviously the
result of it because i have my best
friend you know
and i have the cuniest little monkey
dude and i [ __ ] love him and i love
the whole thing but
i don't know i just i didn't i didn't
there's girls out there and women out
there that love being pregnant my
sister's one of them she's like oh god
it was so beautiful and i loved it and i
loved my belly and i loved feeling all
that and stuff and i just couldn't ever
relate i when i had it i'm like oh yeah
no that's not my
that's not my cup of tea you want to
hear something crazy what you always
wanted to be pregnant no
okay i love being a dad i [ __ ] love
being a mom i love being a that's not
crazy no it is crazy okay because
i love being a dad so much
that
whatever we've built
that um
like from the outside right there's like
people that deem us successful right we
got a big house got cool cars and all
that stuff
um i would give it all away for a
simpler life
like i work at ups or something you know
something where it's like middle class i
like blue collar work versus white
collar working like moving around my atd
is crazy it can't be sitting there all
day but if i could be a cop ups guy
[ __ ] landscape or construction work
or whatever
and it's a solid nine of five i don't
work for you
i go home and i can just be dad
um i actually would love that but kind
of like you i have a lot of loyalty and
uh
endetment that i feel like to to the
team and stuff like that like barbell we
usually got like 20 people that we feed
jk easily 10 15 people that we feed and
we have
families that were just you know
internet families kind of that we all
kind of like support each other
so
you know when you when you are like
in this position of owning a business
and a network like this you can't just
unplug yourself because there is not
only the aftermath but the aftermath to
the aftermath to the aftermath you know
it's like it's like game of thrones yeah
it's like you can't just go why doesn't
he just do this well because if he does
this this person does this and that
person does this and then yeah that's a
dominant thing yeah exactly
but if there was a genie um i didn't
know that being a dad was gonna be so
freaking awesome yeah i would go yeah
dude [ __ ]
sign me up at the [ __ ] local costco
i'll be there packing whatever as long
as i can come home by five and you know
that's how much i love
being a papa yeah i mean you're [ __ ]
awesome dad you're the best at thank you
yeah you're super cool you're super fair
you um
you really validate him
i could cry at so cute
but at the same time though
like saying that what's nuts is
i think no matter what you say
to
show or tell someone
how
they're supposed to live
the best example is always how you live
yeah you know yeah and so i think like
there's the biggest benefit to me
hustling
even though it pulls me away from taika
sometimes
is showing him what hustling is yeah you
know all the immigrant families where
their parents work two jobs or they're
like working at the dry cleaners it's
like it's like yeah they never saw their
dad that much but their work ethic
ironically comes from that which is
crazy i guess it's um i guess it depends
on what it is that you value yeah right
yeah do you value setting up the
generations do you value uh instilling a
lot of um hand on hand lessons you know
with the kid it just depends and that's
the theme that i think both pull it
apart right like even when we have
thatch on
it's like you want the kid to be
comfortable but with comfort comes
coddling
right and then so
um with
with uh like let's say with me being
around more
with that also comes my dad doesn't
hustle as much as that dad does
but on the same token
the more that i hustle
my dad's not around yeah
yeah everything has a as a pro and a con
yeah so like just finding that fine line
yeah
and so for me like what worked out ended
up being was the work schedule that we
have you know we crush it as [ __ ]
hard as we can from seven to three pm
and we pick up tacos some of us wake up
at seven some of us wake up at four
that's what i've been trying to tell you
i wake up at four
yeah but you know like even stuff like
that where tycho's our early bird right
yeah and he wakes up at 5 30. son of a
[ __ ] and he goes to the bed and my
bear's laying there sleeping yeah he
goes to the office and papa's hustling
after him
yeah right it's the opposite i know who
hustles you know yeah right so even like
stuff like that it shows them so it
shows them so much without saying [ __ ]
yeah
you know but just finding that fine line
of how do i show them i'm hustling but
i'm also here for you all the time yeah
that's what it's like what you're trying
to do yeah that one is rough
um
so
yeah i come back to work so i yeah i
just i just didn't like being pregnant
and then um that that sounds like such a
harsh word like i didn't like it like i
love the idea but all moms relate though
the minute you say that
yes queen
yes with their [ __ ] fingernails on
their palm yes
you know like how many moms are like who
the [ __ ] likes throwing up randomly the
first three months yeah there's
i have a lot of girlfriends like [ __ ]
heartburn you know random [ __ ] harper
yeah you're who who's
yeah they're just why is this happening
yeah their bodies just invaded and then
what you had [ __ ] carpal tunnel right
which is like normal like you get
bloating and so you're you're trying to
bench when you're pregnant but your
wrists were just hurting now my [ __ ]
my beautiful fake tits just look real
now what do you mean they're [ __ ]
still sexy they're sexy but i wanted
that fake [ __ ] pamela anderson
they're like right underneath my goddamn
chin i want everyone to know that they
were [ __ ] fake now i'm just getting
so easy to do i know i'm just i'm being
exaggerated i'm trying to be funny
i'm trying to hold back a lot of tears
right now why what because i just did my
makeup and i don't do my makeup i know
what kind of tears oh when i was
describing how cool of a dad you are
like it just like right now i'm choking
up because it's just so cuny but anyway
um what was i saying oh yeah so that i
didn't like it
um i loved after like i loved giving
birth and doing all that stuff because
um i was like holy [ __ ] my body did that
what i look at tycoon now and i'm like
i can't believe i created that
with your seasons and spices and [ __ ]
yeah you're the main ingredient yeah
yeah but like i was the oven you're the
water the flour and the oven yeah yeah
yeah uh which kind of tastes like [ __ ]
if you just put those three and you need
the cinnamon and the frosting how can we
get the good ingredients that's what i
am i think
it literally like when it comes out it
looks like the frosting on the cinnamon
rolls
[Laughter]
so then yeah so then i i didn't like it
and then i i felt guilty the entire time
i was away from the team
i come back and i just tell myself i
don't want to be in that situation
anymore i don't want to i don't want to
experience the unliking the pregnancy
thing and i also don't want to feel
guilty removing myself from the equation
of our businesses physical and emotional
factors
and i i like publicly said online like
no more kids and that one too is um
there's a lot of pressure online you
know like uh i understand where it comes
from and it comes from a place of love
and support and they're like [ __ ] this
this human that you created is so
[ __ ] rad like we want more you know
and like i get where it comes from but
when you hear it literally every [ __ ]
day multiple times a day
um
it's kind of nuts it kind of gets nuts
but it's also
understanding where it comes absolutely
that's why i've said that first for them
what does that mean they're just
regurgitating oh right like
um
when they go
to their grandma's house to their
abuelita's house what are you gonna have
to their nine-nine's house yeah right
they're
same [ __ ] so it's like oh where's your
kid when are you going to get married
all that stuff right so i think like 99
milk
that's neonai oh it's similar oh i see
um but it's like all of that it's comes
from somewhere yeah you know so it's
just to me i i when i read it i go oh
it's just regurgitation yeah but you
read it and it i mean you can never have
a kid
it's not on you
you don't mean like it's on the mom it's
always on the woman yeah
no it's on me too
i'm like you have no say in it what you
have very minimal how are you gonna have
a kid by yourself you're going to have
very i wouldn't be by myself exactly you
have very minimal say i have a lot to
say
what do i mean no when they say like
that stuff i read it too right yeah when
they're like when you're gonna have
another kid you should have another
tiger tech is so cute taking his little
brother little sister or whatever right
yeah i get a lot of pressure too i'm
like [ __ ] you feel pressure too yeah
cause i'm like man i'm so
i'm so used to busting on the back
but don't mind if you don't bust out my
back [ __ ] off i'm gonna bust on the
inside i'm like [ __ ] do i gotta do that
okay jokes aside do you feel pressure
not never not at all no because i
probably because i'm not an emotional
woman you know oh yeah that's why when i
hear it it goes oh regurgitation i get i
get it from or like you know when you
see um you know the guy at the at the
club yeah and he passed his chest out
what dude
yeah i don't know this guy's never been
in a fight before he's just trying to
peacock you know yeah but i think
because i'm so logical or like the gift
and the curse that i'm talking about i'm
like
i'm probably like you know sherlock
holmes with robert downey jr i'm already
calculating oh 70 percent chance this
guy doesn't have cauliflower here look
at his knuckles looks so clean this guy
he's just peacocking so he could avoid
the fight he's he acted so hard a
security guard came this guy doesn't
want any of this [ __ ] you know and um i
can calculate and see what's happening
and then so even with that i'm like okay
cool there's this this is just
regurgitation because i am guilty of the
same [ __ ] i go oh you know when like
aunt had a kid oh dude are you gonna
have another kid and they had enzo or
have another friend have a kid oh you
guys hey the tim cheer you guys don't
have a kid yeah i don't ask that anymore
yeah well for me i'm like i know i
regurgitate something probably a ton of
other people also regularly
so so um yeah with those reasons and
stuff uh i just felt like i was doing it
as a public disservice if i left people
hanging right because i was still kind
of on the fence and the more i thought
about it the more i'm like dude um the
ideal that i wanted of me being at home
with four kids i'm like that's just not
my life my life didn't go in that
direction from the point in which i said
it in my early 20s or my mid-20s when we
got together
so um i kind of just chalked it up as
like okay well life kind of just gave us
different life events and like our paths
went in a different direction because at
that time i was working at the bank you
know there's also that too um so i
understood it for that and i didn't have
any resentment or like sadness over it
you know like partially because i'm like
oh man like what what could it have been
right still nostalgic you still you know
right about it but i mean my life is red
you know i've done so many dope things
like i love the age that we did have our
first kid because at that point we had
multiple businesses we had so much life
experience we traveled the world we got
to like um meet so many people like we
just did things that normal people don't
get to do yeah
um
so i think at that point i'm like yeah i
don't want to do this anymore like i
don't want to have any more kids like
what's wrong with one kid and yeah
people in our circle
uh even online are like oh how can you
do that to taika he's an only child you
know but then we know tim
chantaranzu right who's like i'm an only
kid and i thought it was [ __ ] cool
like i loved it like i didn't feel like
i needed other siblings like the fact
that my parents played with me and gave
me attention like that's that was pure
fulfillment for me yeah so when i was
the only child and i hated it yeah so
like that's the only side i ever saw
yeah
so and i know we're not regular parents
my parents are divorced that's even
worse so not only did i have no siblings
you had no parents i didn't have both
parents at the same time yeah yeah
um yeah your shit's super unique so i
never even use you as as an example for
any of it because divorce is not in my
vocabulary and we're not
your average parents like we're
fortunate enough to have built a life
where we set the schedule we can do what
we want to do whenever we want to do it
we're highly involved in taika's
development and just playing and uh we
go out a lot like we just do a lot of
different things so we're already so
much different than the life that i
was brought into yeah so
with all of these things i i um i had
made my decision and i was pretty okay
so i want to say i was like
90
really about it like really about i'm
stopping at one but that 10 was still
always kind of looming in the back of my
mind it's always been 10 always because
even for me i thought you were like 99.
yeah i mean i like to think about things
a lot especially when it's a big
decision like this
um but i didn't want to leave because i
know i can be indecisive i didn't want
to leave any room for me to
to still stay on the fence about things
so i rather just pick a side
and like commit to that
and then if anything like if i have a
window
to kind of like navigate in i'm still
going to think about it and this one's
not like a set in stone type of thing
when you told me when tycho was two
that you didn't want to anymore to me
that was like 90.
but each day that went by
that you're like put it in my mouth i'm
like that's not how kids are made babe
then i'm like oh 95 you know
and i put it in my butt put in my butt
well okay definitely gonna have kids i
know we didn't have this conversation
because i i think um
i think i i finally reached this
conclusion last month
and the reason why god damn you're
[ __ ] indecisive yeah super it's like
this is a big decision you know this is
a big decision you just gotta say [ __ ]
it sometimes i did and i said [ __ ] it
remember i want i'm like just get a
vasectomy and then at that point it's a
hundred now and i don't have to think
about anything else yeah because i'm
always thinking yeah that's my [ __ ]
problem i think too god that much
um i remember i think i didn't get a
vasectomy right because if you did then
i'm done i don't have to think about it
anymore my job is done we're done i can
move on but because that didn't happen
and you're like wait i'm just gonna
chill because i know you're [ __ ]
indecisive as [ __ ] yeah that's why i was
like you know what i would
but i'm gonna go and tell you i'm gonna
wait until you're biologically expired
right because i'm like this [ __ ] can't
make up her mind for [ __ ] fine just in
case fine so because you said that not
in those terms you were definitely a lot
sweeter you're not doing it for comedy
right now
i'm hard
but because you left it at that then i
left it open as well so then um
for the next couple of years i kept
thinking about it and i'm like okay i'm
38 now at this point recently
uh i'm like okay i really have to decide
now if this is if this is just the one
and done
then
that's it i need to get that [ __ ] out of
my mind and it needs to get cemented now
because it was just kind of like on one
cement for a few years
and then i really thought about it for
this whole entire year of like the
37 38 or what
um before even vegas like i always
thought about it
and then we come to vegas um
vegas didn't really have much to do with
it but the fact that
it was more suburban life more so than
where we used to live in glendora
things were
things are crazier now but like are
slowing down which is really cool
that i'm going oh [ __ ] okay i can start
seeing
um some type of normalcy in my life
right because everything's always just
kind of been go go go go go go go go
[ __ ] new opportunity take it this is
coming up take it say yes to this say
yes to this it was always that
that now enrolling tyke into school
having him be on in like you know in
school now like he's like dressing
himself feeding himself giving his he
takes his own showers like he's so
independent
that i'm going oh [ __ ] like life is
[ __ ] happening but it's also slowing
down so
i'm like
[ __ ]
i go we did that thing you know where we
always go like 10 years into the future
20 years into the future 30 whatever
and like in the past i would look into
that and i'm like i think it's cool you
know i think it's cool that it'll just
be us three and like other family
members when it when we have our
holidays and stuff
um
tycho have his friends come over
significant other like it's not it's
never gonna be just us three
and then um
i don't know something one day just
clicked that it's like
no you should just have one more and i'm
like i'm like arguing in my own head
going but wait why like we didn't want
it at all what the hell is changing now
like what what was the deciding factor
um and ultimately
it came down to
yeah one just wasn't enough
i tell you something what
if we're still in la
i don't think i would want a second one
what
so like
when i look at things and this probably
goes back to like the gift part of
things
when when you buy like a car right
people are just using that looking at
the price tag i'm looking at insurance
registration car repairs
like that kind of stuff right do we have
any parking spaces or is our driveway
tandem if it's tandem i don't think we
should have more than two cards and be a
pain in the mass move like i just think
about a lot of stuff that's just how the
way my brain works
and the way
that la is shaped
like in the type of activities i want
tyka to have
and the type of involvement i want with
the family it's almost impossible
so like how is vegas more possible
there's no family out here and i'm
explaining i'll explain right now okay
you know when
since we moved to vague so i'll address
the extracurricular activities part and
i'll address the family part
extract curricular activities wise
i grew up and i think this is probably a
very standard asian upbringing you do
martial arts swimming and some sort of
musical instrument
in la the way that it's built
those three places are at least 30
minutes apart
that's one kid
so after school
three
rushed somewhere 3 30
3-4 rush somewhere else four four thirty
you're not going to have a kid
you know literally after school until
nine
is activities and driving most of it
driving
and you're not gonna have a kid you're
not gonna have any bonding time the
weekend we want to go on a hike and
stuff like that forget about it it's
it's slammed it's so hard right so you
want to do that multiplied by two
it's so difficult coming from asia you
saw how convenient stuff is right like
my cousin he gets out of school rides
his bike five minutes that's where
tutoring is rides his bike five minutes
that's where swimming is and i think
that mentality of like you have all
these extracurricular activities from
asia
after five you do like four things
you're back home for dinner by seven
still you get to hang out the whole
night bond talk about everything that
you did in l.a at least where we live
and that was almost impossible times two
that would have been freaking crazy
out here that was one of the things that
i've been gauging right when we drive
tic taika to jiu jitsu but would they
both be in the same quest no
their interests we want them to be the
same we could have a girl and one wants
to do ballet or something or she wants
to play baseball or soccer then you're
just [ __ ] you know not really i
mean you can always plan it like you can
tuesday wednesday whatever is this
thursday friday saturday you can you can
you can you can try to be strategic
about it right yeah but i'm just i like
to look at things worst case and best
case scenario so when i'm driving around
in vegan i'm not just saying vegas for
vegas i'm talking about it could have
been texas probably or anyone that's
just not so congested it could be tulsa
oklahoma
but when i drive around and
it feels like in la you're trying to do
like what's the term where you put like
a square pig in a circle
right that toy yeah it feels like people
are trying to force a suburb life in a
city and that's the part that's tough
whereas um
non-la the suburb feels like a suburb or
even maybe even further away from
probably rancho glucomanca you already
feel like this so that's why i'm not
saying it's really a la or non-la thing
it's more of a city versus suburb thing
but then also because we're in
entertainment we're forced to be in the
city
you know so being forced to be in the
city i'm like man that that doesn't
really work out and since we are so now
addressing the family part of it
when we are in
the same vicinity like how many times
did my dad come visit us how many times
does your brother come visit us how many
times did we come visit your brother
because we're right in that distance
where you're like okay we know we're
close but then we also take each other
for granted but it's also just far away
enough where we don't plan for it it is
a whole day activity you know so it's
that like
perfect medium where it's just like you
know what a phone call and a text
will suffice like a month or whatever
right now that we're away
we value each other so much we miss each
other
so we can't wait to plan the next
holiday it could be two months away are
we coming to you guys coming to me like
next weekend we're just straight up
gonna go visit your mom because you miss
her so now it's so much more intentional
versus this like take it for granted
being on the side and now my dad is like
dude i miss you guys so much i have to
move here
right so he's gonna move here he's gonna
uproot himself whatever
um errands or whatever like routine he
had going on he's leaving that coming to
vegas strictly for taika and us
and that's how intentional it is
and so like seeing that and like kind of
the effects of not living in the city
and also how the family reacts and how
um
the gatherings are less
frequent but more intense
i'm like cool this is what i want and if
we bring in a second one
it feels like there's enough space to
live the type of life that i would want
for them i see yeah that's what for me
if we were still in la
and i'm like damn it's gonna take like
30 minutes to an hour to do anything
like
if once my dad lives here
uh
my dad's house is already five minutes
away from tykasujitsu
we could like literally have dinner at
his house every night after just if we
wanted
versus an la [ __ ] that's almost
impossible it had to be on the weekends
you know
yeah
yeah
that makes sense i get it um
yeah but for me it was uh thinking all
of that i wasn't necessarily thinking
that because
that to me is not an issue because i had
such a dope mom
that even when she had multiple kids she
made it all work she took my sister to
softball she took my brother to golf she
would take me to art classes or dance
classes my little sister to her classes
and she was always very much involved so
but no one has a black belt
it doesn't matter so for me it was like
um i know it's doable it's not doable
taking someone to softball
versus taking someone to softball from
first grade to a senior year in high
school is way different yeah that's what
i'm talking about
the life that i live
my mom was able to guarantee
if i got into an activity
regardless of what life circumstance my
mom had surgery too but you don't even
have a black belt in anything i do have
a black own kung fu
you know like it's like to be able to uh
make sure someone does something for 10
years
you say kung fu for 10 years yeah oh
[ __ ] that's that's different yeah you
know what i mean
so like um
that that's what i mean by like i don't
want to dabble oh yeah my kid play
two-year softball like dude that's
that's [ __ ] that's peanuts that's
easy yeah that's also different like
your parent your mom's way of doing [ __ ]
is pretty gnarly um but also when you
meet people in the like the big leagues
like once you go to like d1 school
status and you talk to people for the
most part you feel like they're all
forced no no when you see people that
are successful
that success is built off the backbone
of something else yeah like mario who we
just talked to right her intense drive
comes from her doing ballet for 20 years
yeah you know and then i've what i've
seen is people that haven't been able to
live that they give up fast
if people have done softball for two
years that's all they can give after two
years they're gonna give up on what
every other thing they rinse and repeat
they're like oh man it seems like
nothing is going well for me once i i
apologize but your parents didn't really
hook you up with a good strong backbone
to keep going at things yeah you know
yeah
um
yeah i mean i get where you're coming
from but that yeah that wasn't a
consideration for me um it was more so
what
type of mom i could be to
more than one
because as it is i was already so busy
that i'm like dude that's not going to
be fair because in my mind
there's an ideal and there's a standard
that i want to live up to
and yeah i didn't feel like um i was
going to be able to do that up until i
really started thinking like [ __ ] okay
this is really the last year i'm going
to push it i've even said this [ __ ]
online too a little bit where i'm like
that's it this is this is a year you
know
um
yeah and like i kept thinking of
everything and then
you know uh even thinking of like the
moment that we pass and i'm like oh man
tyka's literally all by himself like
that's it
like you right like you're all by
yourself that's it
you don't have anyone else to really
like hit up about stuff even though i
have more siblings and we just weren't
that tight that doesn't necessarily just
because you have more siblings doesn't
necessarily guarantee closeness or like
support in that way yeah my dad and his
brother beefed until my grandpa passed
yeah and they still don't talk the thing
though is as dysfunctional as my family
is
i know if [ __ ] really hits the fan i
know i can hit them up
right like we hit each other i mean we
hit we hate each other
but if [ __ ] really hits the fan like if
some [ __ ] like
the world we start going into world war
i don't know [ __ ]
three right now
um
then
me and my sister who like are not that
tight i'll call her up yo we gotta get
together
cool it's done you know
so um i know i i even feel like that for
your pops right like there's yeah you're
uh they're beefing or whatever but if
some real [ __ ] [ __ ] happens where
people need to band together i'm sure
they're going to pick each other before
they pick a lot of other strangers you
know
no yeah
okay like my grandpa passed and he was
begging and those two still couldn't
squash it yeah
ten years later my dad's brothers died
and then that's it didn't even go to his
funeral
okay well so i'm like i almost only
speak for myself yeah so then like
playing all those scenarios in my head
and thinking about and this is stuff
that i've like replayed in my head for
[ __ ] years from the moment i said no
more
i i still kept going like okay but wait
like are you really considering every
single side are you really considering
like your feelings like i
definitely want to consider you
because i i as much as it is my body and
it is like you know me deciding because
i am putting a lot more into it than you
are like there's a lot more sacrifice on
the frosting i keep telling you though
yeah cinnamon roll without the frost is
disgusting yeah anyway um but because
i'm
i'm doing the most sacrificing and i am
the more emotional one uh i still have
to
respect you and and consider you and
going well yeah but i'm not a single
[ __ ] parent yeah you know
um and you also know the emotional
punching bag i turn into once you are
pregnant
so you know that shut up why are you
talking so much [ __ ] right now
[ __ ] when i talk [ __ ] i can see your
goddamn [ __ ] mug right now i'll
[ __ ] straight up kick you i'm long
dude you are pretty low
so yeah so like always thinking about i
had always thought about it yeah
and then um
yeah it just hit me like like i i want
it you know like i want one more
and um
yeah this will literally be the last
year like if it happens cool if not
cool yeah
i mean as much as i say i do all the
calculations and stuff
i always try to prepare for a perfect
world right
um but also
i understand that the world is chaotic
so it's always kind of like
um i mean like the military you get
taught this but i feel like a lot of
people also teach this where you
you uh
you you prepare for the best but you
always expect the worst
right so for me i'm like if we weren't
in la
i don't want to do it it's not the life
or in the city that's not the life i
would want for our kids
but like let's say we doesn't even make
sense though like you say that but it's
like yeah then we move it's not a big
deal yeah but that wasn't in the cards
for us we talked about moving so much we
were just oh we can't because we we're
just tied to this that type of that like
no but we also talked about once um
once taika is older and whatever then
it's like then yeah we are more mobile
and we do have to decide like
like we knew it wasn't going to be our
end-all be-all because we still had
taika school and stuff yeah which we
moved to a place i had a school good
school district even in l.a yeah you
know but i think we weren't really we
didn't know we could move until the
pandemic happened which was
kind of a blessing in disguise
for our scheduling yeah where with jk
we're like [ __ ] this is early pandemic
so we need to keep shooting because we
feed like 20 something people
but at the same time
we don't have the funds to like have a
doctor on set we covet tests weren't
even available so we're like well based
off the cdc quarantine for 14 days
so let's just shoot every 14 days and
then we'll keep each other updated if
everyone's symptomatic or whatever and
we kept doing that and no one got sick
for like a whole year you know where
people that were sick they stayed out
for the whole two weeks and we didn't
see them for another month and through
that was when i think started opening up
everyone's eyes right for us we're like
oh [ __ ] only twice a month
maybe we could live somewhere else for
joe's like oh [ __ ] only twice a month
that like international nomadic
lifestyle i've been wanting to live i
can do that and everyone's starting to
able to like
like pursue what they wanted you know so
i think for us
like i like to calculate
and like you know really mitigate risk
and stuff and see what's most plausible
but once we started moving out of la and
things were becoming like oh [ __ ] like
we could live a more chill life
that's when i was
yeah let's in my mind without having
talking to you just in my mind doing my
own thoughts i was like oh i think
that's more possible i'd be down yeah
but of course like i say i always
prepare for
i'm ready for anything so i'm like if we
did i get accidentally pregnant in l.a i
would keep them of course you know i'm
like okay [ __ ] this is i [ __ ] i'll
do whatever it takes that's crazy i
didn't even know that you didn't want
one if we were still in l.a
i guess you didn't even have to voice it
because i was so convincing
well i also
am multi-layered all the time you know
like everything
why are you able to be multi-layered but
i'm the one that's indecisive
what do you mean because i'm also
multi-layered
i'm decisively multi-layered so am i no
you're indecisively multiple i'm not
indecisive you're just talking [ __ ]
again am i yeah maybe thank you you're
welcome
yeah um
but
yeah and then just kind of like seeing
how quickly kids grow
you know like he's four all of a sudden
he's four but going on ten like we're
having some yeah like we're having so
many like
intellectual
deep conversations
like he's expressing some deep emotions
and like
he he he puts together really deep jokes
yeah i'm like what the [ __ ] like he was
just afraid of
um of being blown away
he thought the wind it gets really windy
in vegas and he thought that like he was
gonna get blown away you guys have to
watch that vlog there's this vlog where
me and tyka go to the park
and um
or we're playing the backyard and
in the park yeah he literally thought
we'd get blown away and it took us a
week
to help them get rid of that fear and
now he like when the wind blows like he
makes fun of him makes fun of himself
he'll be like oh well i'm going to blow
away
and he's pretending like he's blown away
yeah and i'm like dude that's such a
complex joke to make to laugh at
yourself now and you're only four
so seeing how quickly he's grown and i
love him so much that i'm just like
dude how rad would it be to have just
one more [ __ ] around and like
nipping at his ankles like he's like a
little puppy now you know little bud um
and i'm like dude that'd be so cool and
i think it's a perfect age gap like it's
not big at all it's gonna be maybe four
or five years
that's perfect yeah it'll be five years
yeah it'll be five years
um yeah and there were just too many
pluses now and i think it was because my
life started slowing down
that i'm like i don't want to do new
things i don't want to do bigger i don't
want to do any of that like i just want
a break yeah i want to break and i want
to feel
um
i want to feel little
you know if that makes sense no um being
in the public eye not that you feel not
big in like a good way but you feel like
you need to be everywhere at once like
you need to be responsive and engaging
and you need to be like thinking of the
next thing and being aware of what's in
like the trends are and like you have to
be on a lot yeah you know and and like
like
when i already scheduled that shooting
date with all the buds yeah and i'm like
hell yeah i haven't done something for
myself in a long time i want to go
shooting and then i get the email you're
cordially invited to the whatever asian
american golfing and i'm like oh [ __ ] i
need to be there because every anybody
that is anybody in the asian american
circle is gonna be there
and i haven't seen all my friends in a
long time i should go there this is so
good
and then i was like
but man that's just gonna be one more
time i don't do something for myself
yeah and and it's so hard to not go yeah
and i don't want it to come off as
ungrateful because i wouldn't be here
where i'm at like i feel so blessed
and i'm so grateful and i and i don't
take any of this stuff for granted
but
also when it comes to like youtube
specifically or when it comes to your
own personal life no when it comes to
youtube specifically
there's no such thing as taking a break
from it if you take a break you die you
know
um
and like
um
it it gets like um
you need a break
you know like
um
it's been such a crazy year for everyone
i feel like starting with 2020 and the
uncertainty of that and like being told
you're constantly gonna die and like
stay away from everyone you love and it
becomes very isolating and like
um we're still not back to normal and
it's this weird normal so there's just
so many things oh and then us moving out
here and like moving out here completely
by ourselves no family no friends
um there were just too many things that
i started feeling like oh [ __ ] like
i i want to i want to do things for
myself as you're talking about you know
like i want to
not have to think about building
anything
like i love building
and i love creating
but like
i'm at a point right now where i'm like
i've done it for like almost 15 years
straight no real breaks
that i'm like okay wait
what
and we're all evolving and growing right
we're we're living different we're
taking in different life experiences
that start molding us
you know and that's where this wisdom
starts coming in so the geo that
everybody knew
back in 2008 when i first
appeared online to the geo that's now
here in 2022 is completely different
woman you know like i've gone through so
much you've gone through so much like
anyone in life should be going through
so much right like in the real world
um that hopefully we've all evolved and
whatever dumb [ __ ] we were saying in the
past um we're saying less of that or
like we're just
matured now and different and we just
have different viewpoints on it
but um
yeah just feeling how
the world has kind of morphed and
changed for me personally
me wanting to be more private me wanting
to like really build my own personal
life and my own personal network and
stuff and pulling back from a lot of the
stuff that i show
online sounds like um
really good
excuse me it sounds like um the move i
want to make right now i felt like one
of the healthiest things that i've seen
from like celebrities
was
justin timberlake and jessica biel
you know like those guys man when you
got that kind of fame where it's like
michael jackson fame you can't even go
to the grocery store you can't even like
i don't think they're good one because
justin timberlake has had such a shitty
year but let's talk about jay-z and
beyonce
what do you mean i don't know he just
got caught up in just a bunch of dumb
[ __ ] that he did oh he did yeah oh [ __ ]
i didn't even know well i guess like
excluding that because i'm not aware of
that the part that i i just the public
um that i that i saw that i was like oh
that's pretty cool is um when they had a
baby they just moved to montana
and they just cut out
from all of the the because you know
like in entertainment it's not just the
content it's the content and the press
and all that that stuff that comes with
it right and um for him like he was like
you know i'm just coming with b out of
the social eye
and him and jessica biel went out into
montana
super like woods suburbs
and just had and just lived there for
three years
i'm like wow how good is that you know
to be able to just focus on the family
yeah and it's important dial in the
things that are important yeah you know
the people that you actually know face
to face yeah rather than trying to feel
like you're always servicing people that
you don't know
yeah which i didn't have an issue with
um
because obviously we're we're not
we're not um
we're true to who we are so it never
feels like i'm putting on this fake
person
um
that's why there's so many different
versions of geo throughout the years
because everyone has seen me literally
grow up
which is crazy oh [ __ ] that's literally
what has happened like everyone has seen
me long hair geo
[ __ ]
super awkward to now [ __ ] shaving my
head my first tattoo uh we reveal that
we're together our marriage like
literally everything has been put out
there like our sex life like
everything is out there
um
but it's all real yeah um if if i'm a
[ __ ] it's because you know i'm a [ __ ]
if i'm like nice it's because you know
i'm nice and that's literally how like
what you see is what you get type of
[ __ ]
um and and it's kind of cool
that you know we are vlogging and we are
live like we do our day-to-day vlogs and
stuff and that tycoop really likes it
yes it makes it easy there's because i
remember we would talk about all the
time as soon as psycho hit school i want
to pull him out yeah uh from like our
vlogs and stuff but he gets so sad if i
vlog and i don't include him there's
multiple vlogs out [ __ ] me mama remember
yeah i think i wasn't even vlogging i
think i was doing a story we were eating
with joe recently and i was like
recording just the food right i'm like
oh joe got this hannah got this papa got
this and i got this and i stopped it and
then taika was ready with his plate
he was ready to show me and i stopped
and he goes mom you're not going to show
them what i'm eating you're not going to
show what i'm eating i want to talk
about it i was like
oh excuse me i'm sorry so then i do and
he goes i have chicken and i have rice
with the flag and i was like oh that's
really cool you know
what's cuny is he doesn't even know who
them is no he doesn't he's just like we
gotta tell them it kind of sounds like
dj khaled you know what it's like they
don't want you to succeed you're like
yeah who's today yeah
um
yeah but he likes it you know so so
vlogging is one of those things that i
view as just my digital um
my digital uh diaries uh journal [ __ ]
the picture book
uh photo album oh okay yeah it's just
now now a digital photo album which is
super rad that uh we get to keep
and that's not something i ever see us
ever stopping because regardless if we
get views or not
it's really cool to just have it there
and then whenever it is that we get the
[ __ ] the yearning to go back to that
point in time you have it you know
um
but yeah now i'm at a point where i'm
like oh [ __ ] i need to i really want to
focus on this new dynamic you know
because we focused on us as a dynamic
and then this new kid came into the
picture becomes a new dynamic but we're
still running where now it's really been
super cool that like
we have a schedule like a parent family
schedule like we wake up at six get him
ready by sevenish he's leaving to go to
school we work by 2 45 we pick him up
we buy him snacks 2 45 to like 3 45 then
he gets his jiu jitsu practice then we
get dinner like it's like this rinse and
repeat like every single day it's the
same schedule i love it i think it's
super cuny yeah i love it too
um
and and i like that and i really want to
like
dig into that more and like lean into
that more and then the idea of having
another little buddy in the picture i'm
like that's [ __ ] cute and i never
thought that
um i really felt
in like
my [ __ ] bones that i'm like that's it
i can only do one
like that like my life is too crazy i
don't want anything else like we're
perfect he's awesome we're awesome as
the three of us
but again like as things start slowing
down and the more i want you know to
take back
a little bit more privacy and stuff that
sounds weird it's not a privacy thing
but i think it's just me focusing more
um
on my wants yeah on you yeah
and myself
um which was a big theme for me back in
2021 at the end of 2020 when like
you know i just had a lot of different
eye-opening
experiences that really taught me a lot
about like life and relationships and
and
those dynamics and stuff and what i
wanted in my life
but come 2022 or the end of 2021 i'm
like yeah this is what i want and it
blew my i blew myself away because i was
so about not having another kid
that i'm like wait [ __ ] like we said no
like what happened where are we why is
it a yes and i even had to convince
myself and not convince myself because
it's a of someone else's want but to be
like wait no i need to check you on it
like are you for real like are we really
gonna do this [ __ ] like is this what you
really want and i'm like yeah like it
surprised me too absolutely because i
remember i busted in a condom and i
threw in a trash can and you got a q-tip
and you're like sticking in the condom
and you're putting it back up your
vagina what are you doing babe shut the
[ __ ] up this is what you had me dude
like this is what groupies do this
groupies this is what groupies do to nba
basketball players
and then it's a lie i knew you were
lying because you flushed it down the
toilet no and then i saw you like
poking holes in my condos i'm like hey
what the hell is going on you don't have
to do that yours full of [ __ ] you wish i
wanted that nasty [ __ ] that bad
you wish you wish i wanted that come you
know what else like really helped me um
no but really were you surprised
i was okay remember i was like i really
thought it was like
90 and then 95 and 99 and i was like
okay she's uh
getting to that blue cheese age that i'm
like i don't know if you want any more
of this cheese because it's kind of like
i don't know it smells like you should
just throw it out the back your cheese
no you're blue cheese why does it why
don't you have cheese
what do you mean because guys keep
making that fresh cheese until they're
like 75. all right
and then so i was like um
yeah i think we're done
so when he told me i was like oh [ __ ]
like it kind of like rattled my brain
and it kind of like
you know i kind of have like this rough
outline of what the next five years look
like and it was like shh like i just
sketched you know
oh it's a new one and i started
etch-a-sketching and then just started
feeling cunier yeah and i've always like
looked
at um
you know we take taika to jiu jitsu
and those families i think that helps
yeah the families that have like like
brothers like and sisters really cuny i
think that definitely i always looked at
them with very fond eyes you know
because i'm like you see the bigger kid
in the big kid class then you see the
little kid and that little kid like
there's that one family that has like
four kids and there's the kid in the big
kid class and then there's like two kids
in the big kid class two in the small
but the kid that used to be in the
little kid cast went into the big kid
class and then there's a little kid in
the little kid class and then there's
the extra baby guy that was always on
the mama's lap and now he's joining the
class yeah he's just like there you know
like dangling his feet because the
chair's too high and he's looking at his
other three siblings and um he's just
like oh cool and then you see him jump
in jump out you know because sometimes
he's not ready because he's actually
even small in taika so he's not even
ready for it so he'll do 10 minutes of
the class and he jumps out of it and the
coach is cool with that you know
and i just see that and there's all
these other families and i'm just like
oh so cuny you know yeah that for sure
was another
uh another factor when i was looking and
when i was just kind of like about it
and you see how good the little kids are
that have the bigger sibling guy or girl
in the big kids class you know because
she's like oh they practice they pass
all these things along like all the kids
that have an older brother or sister
yeah they're little stud muffins yeah
well yeah that's where we're at with it
so
um you guys are getting absolutely
exclusive news don't know when we'll
like make a video about this we have so
much news we want to share with you guys
that we've kind of been withholding but
definitely um
continue to support the youtube channel
um we're going to start doing different
content on there and we're going to
start doing a lot more life updates
because there's just life has been
happening so quickly out here
that we just haven't been documenting
that part of it but we will start
releasing it so
this part at least
you guys are getting the exclusive on
that yeah this is going to be the last
year that we try
and if it happens awesome and if it
doesn't happen then it wasn't meant to
be and it's still very much awesome but
thank you guys for the continued support
throughout the years it's been really
dope um sharing our life with you guys
and and i hope that none of this ever
came off as complaining or anything this
is just a very vulnerable take on things
that you know we do go through
um as people that have shared so much
online so thank you so much for allowing
us to to grow in front of you guys and
to experience life and and make our
mistakes and have our victories and
stuff it's been really dope to share
everything um and get your guys's
positive feedback and just feedback on
it honestly like um
i always enjoy feedback i hate [ __ ]
trolls but i enjoy feedback so thank you
so much love you guys so much and we
will continue doing our best for you
thank you bye